[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal
nous sommes le jeudi 20 février voici
les titres qui seront à développer dans
cette édition le 14 janvier dernier plus
de 1000 médecins à travers le territoire
se disait prêt à démissionner pour
alerter sur la dégradation de l'hôpital
public
plusieurs médecins yvelinois étaient
concernés un mois après quelle est la
situation nous poserons la question de
docteur philippe rousselot chef de
service à l'hôpital minots du chéné rock
en cours et c'est un secteur en pleine
croissance entre 2014 et 2016 près de 5
millions de maisons individuelles ont
fait l'objet de rénovations énergétiques
une activité boosté par les aides de
l'état
illustration dans ce journal avec une
entreprise spécialisée dans ce domaine
est basée à trappes
nous nous intéresserons également à la
migration des batraciens la saison a
démarré une épreuve qui peut avoir
malheureusement des conséquences fatales
pour ces animaux pour éviter cela à des
associations les aident à traverser la
route afin de les empêcher de se faire
écraser
mais avant de développer et ses titres j
- 2 avant le début du salon de
l'agriculture à paris est l'occasion
notamment de découvrir les produits mais
aussi plus généralement l'agriculture
francilienne
à cette occasion la présidente de la
région ile de france valérie pécresse a
annoncé quatre priorités pour ce secteur
en 2020 plus de détails avec nos
confrères de via grand paris convertir
l'agriculture francilienne au bio c'est
l'une des priorités de la région
ile-de-france valérie pécresse a
présenté ses objectifs pour 2020
aujourd'hui trente mille hectares
franciliens sont cultivés en agriculture
biologique
c'est trois fois plus qu'en 2015 le
pacte écologique signé en 2018 doit
encore permettre d'accélérer en jeu
quarante cinq mille hectares cultivés en
une menace le désengagement de l'état
l'état supprime ces aides
alors que va faire la région et bien
toutes les aides supprimés par l'état la
région va les remplacer
donc nous allons nous substituer à un
état défaillant sur le bio pour que les
agriculteurs bio qui se sont engagés
dans cette démarche qui ont fait les
investissement c'est très lourd de la
transition bio et bien ne soit pas en
insécurité et pour qu'on garde cette
formidable dynamique de transition vers
l'agriculture biologique
autre priorité de la région développer
les circuits courts en rapprochant
citoyens et agriculteurs une centrale
d'achat va être mise en place pour
fournir les 463 lycées d'île de france
avec 100 % de produits franciliens dont
50 % de bio d'ici à 2024 14 produits
déjà identifié les carottes les pommes
de terre les lentilles les pommes les
poires la baguette des franciliens mais
aussi la volaille les oeufs la viande
donc vraiment et la banane des outre
mers parce que la balle à l'antillaise
nous la considérons comme un produit
deux circuits courts en ile de france
autre défi assurer la relève des
agriculteurs et surtout rajeunir la
profession aujourd'hui un agriculteur
sur cinq a plus de 60 ans nous
travaillons évidemment avec les jeunes
agriculteurs
nous avons fait un site avec qui promeut
le les métiers de l'agriculture nous
avons une agriculture qui est encore
très familiale en ile de france et on
veut la garder
donc ça suppose de d'encourager tous ces
jeunes agriculteurs à s'installer à
prendre la succession de leurs parents
de leurs familles et puis aussi
d'attirer des nouveaux et ça aussi c'est
l'objet de notre plan de formation
depuis 2016 4200 formations ont été
financés par la région ile de france il
ya un peu plus d'un mois plus de 1000
médecins signé une tribune et menacé de
démissionner pour dénoncer une
dégradation des conditions de travail
des équipes hospitalières parmi les
signataires le docteur philippe
rousselot bonsoir moi vous êtes chef de
service hématologie oncologie à
l'hôpital mignot au chesnay et
rocquencourt première question toute
simple
avez vous démissionné je n'ai pas encore
démissionné nous sommes très en retard
dans les yvelines sur les démissions est
actuellement 1000 médecins
démissionnaires qui est inscrit sur la
liste qui ont effectivement démissionné
et j'espère qu'on va pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre sa démission effective d'ici la
fin du mois de février sont les yvelines
vous voulez coordonnées peut-être un peu
plus justement
sera ce mouvement tout cas dans les
yvelines je crois capable départements
qui ont essayé de coordonner les choses
et annoncer de façon globale les
médecins démissionnaires donc je pense
que c'est ce qu'on va essayer de faire
sur les yvelines a encore donnant les
différents hôpitaux l'hôpital andré
mignot a empoché n'est l'hôpital de
mantes-la-jolie l'hôpital de rambouillet
rappel c'est une des mines une démission
administrative du service ratissent le
dire que on ne quitte pas nos factures
ni de soins ni d'anciennes mandine de
recherche
mais c'est vrai qu'on se met en retrait
un petit peu des questionnements
administratif qui font un peu le
quotidien
la chef de service à l'hôpital public
pourquoi finalement avoir choisi cette
menace symbolique mais je pense ça fait
du bruit déjà ça a été juste étaient
visibles d'ailleurs on en parle je pense
a fait bouger un petit peu aussi les
choses sur le plan du ministère
ce qui a eu des avancées qui ont été
obtenus la suite à cette à ces
démissions et puis je crois aussi créé
un symbole très fort de l'unité du
mouvement au niveau national à revenir
sur vos revendications vous dénoncez
notamment un mal être justement dans
dans les hôpitaux lancé bien ça alors
c'est bien ça il ya trois revendications
clés à la première c'est l'attractivité
des métiers à l'hôpital en particulier
des métiers soignants et des métiers
techniques avec une demande de
revalorisation salariale
la deuxième c'est ça concerne le budget
global de l'hôpital c'est à dire qu'on
considère qu'actuellement depuis dix ans
ce budget a baissé et permet plus à
l'hôpital d'investir dans l'avenir
et puis la troisième revendications
sinon revendications de gouvernance avec
une meilleure coordination entre les
soignants et les directions
hospitalières
le manque de moyens vous le voyez par
exemple à l'hôpital mignon par le manque
de moyens on le voit oui parce que le
talent du milieu est déficitaire
donc il a fait de gros investissements
l'hôpital mignot et on traîne maintenant
ce déficit sur des années et d'ailleurs
ce déficit peut nous empêcher de le
réinvestir à nouveau pour moi d'être
modernisé l'hôpital donc oui c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit dans le
quotidien
alors le 14 février dernier vous avez
remis un recueil de lettres d'amour à
votre hôpital ainsi qu'à l'elysée et à
matignon
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
sur ce qu'il y avait à l'intérieur de ce
recueil en fait l'objectif c'était
d'essayer de montrer l'attachement et
des soignants et du public et donc des
usagers comme on dit vis-à-vis de leur
institution hospitalière dans le hall de
l'hôtel me on a fait 1
rancoeur sur lequel les soignants et les
usagers pouvaient noter leurs
impressions sur des post it un franc
succès et on a pu lire également des
lettres à la fois émanant de soignants
et maintenant également de patients sur
leur histoire avec l'hôpital public donc
effectivement crois que c'est très
important de mettre en avant aussi les
missions de l'hôpital public qui sont
des missions de soins pour quiconque
indépendamment de critères de ressources
ou de critères sociaux
vous avez un retour du gouvernement
retour je ne suis pas sûr que le livre
en question est encore été
officiellement transmis mais il est en
cours de fabrication en plus l'actualité
récente m'a fait qu'il ya désormais à
nouveau un ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand est ce que ça change quelque
chose pour vous alors actuellement il ya
une délégation du collectif inter
hôpitaux qui en feront même reçu par le
ministère et par la ministre
ça change quelque chose probablement que
ça peut changer quelque chose je pense
que si on a une écoute un peu différente
peut-être que les choses avanceront les
demandes sont les mêmes vous avez vu il
n'a pas eu beaucoup d'avancées jusqu'à
présent est peut-être plus misé quelques
qu'un début de négociations pourraient
faire avancer les choses on peut donc
peut-être que s'il ya une négociation en
cours plutôt que des postures de part et
d'autre ça serait une façon de faire
avancer les choses
quelles sont vos prochaines actions
imprévues alors voudrais inviter un
petit peu dans la campagne des
municipales crois que c'est d'actualité
je pense qu'il faut que toutes et tous
ont soit bien investi du fait que la
santé c'est un sujet important et je
voudrais lancer un appel à nos élus qui
nous regardent et éventuellement de
mettre en avant la santé l'hôpital
public au coeur de leurs préoccupations
et d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle aussi on va vers les usagers en
leur demandant de questionner leurs
futurs élus les candidats sur le
problème de la santé d'hôpital public
lors de cette élection municipale donc
vous devriez démissionner
administrativement rappelle bien sûr à
la fin de la fin du mois tu vois là oui
parce qu'on peut pour pas être non plus
le dernier des derniers à démissionner
donc
donc je pense qu'on va être
effectivement dans les derniers hôpitaux
à mettre ça en place mais mais encore
une fois ça n'affecte pas le soin aux
patients
combien de médecins vous pouvez rappeler
dans le temps les yvelines un peu près
alors on sera pas plus que 10 1 je pense
même si on a appris d'une réunion des
chefs de services de l'hôtel mignola
prochainement pour essayer justement
d'avoir une attitude coordonnée autour
de tout ça même s'il n'a pas forcément
énormément démission aura des soutiens
et les soutiens je pense aussi important
que la démission effective
merci philippe rousselot d'être venu sur
notre plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
chef de service hématologie et oncologie
à l'hôpital minot enchaîné au concours
est la police yvelinoise vient de lancer
un appel à témoins pour tenter
d'identifier le corps d'un homme à la
gare de la verrière
il a été retrouvé le 4 février dernier
il s'agit d'un homme d'environ 70 ans
cheveux courts et blanc est si vous
pensez avoir des informations vous
pouvez joindre le groupe d'appui
judiciaire du commissariat d'elancourt
au numéro qui s'affiche sur l'écran
à 24 jours du premier tour des élections
municipales nous continuons à faire le
tour des communes pour mieux connaître
leurs enjeux problèmes de circulation
logement ou encore diminution du nombre
de médecins
nous nous rendons ce soir à voisins le
bretonneux avec manon varaldo voisins le
bretonneux compte 11000 426 habitants en
2020 mais elle a perdu 1000 habitants en
15 ans malgré la production de 590
logement ces dernières années à voisins
le bretonneux les projets immobiliers se
succèdent 29 logements dans le centre 95
logements dans le quartier du lac ou
encore 110 logements à la grande île
des projets vont également sortir de
terre c'est le cas à rue hélène boucher
et 18 logements vont voir le jour à
prévoir pour 2022 sur ce terrain vague
la construction de l'écoquartier la zone
d'aménagement concerté du quartier et de
la remise comptera 500 logements avec
notamment un parc arboré et des jardins
partagés voisins le bretonneux n'a que
18,5 pour cent 2
logements sociaux contre 25 % exigés par
l'état d'ici 2025
le point noir la circulation à voisins
le bretonneux lieu de transit entre la
vallée de chevreuse et saint quentin en
yvelines
les carrefours sont des points de
ralentissements en heure de pointe en
jeu également le nouveau cimetière le
projet de construction d'un troisième
cimetière à la place du square des 40
arpents a été contestée un collectif
s'est constitué pour s'opposer à sa
création
après ce mouvement de contestation deux
autres terrains potentiels sont à
l'étude ou en passe de l'être
enfin autre inquiétude pour l'ebit
sinois la moitié des médecins
généralistes partent bientôt à la
retraite et ne prennent pas de nouveaux
patients pour pallier cette pénurie les
habitants attendent une maison de santé
pluriprofessionnelle elle devrait être
construite à l'emplacement de l'ancien
leader price au centre de la grande île
des généralistes et spécialistes sont
recherchés et je vous rappelle que dans
le cadre des élections municipales tv
soit 118 en association avec radio
sensations à vous propose des débats
entre les candidats ce soir émission
consacrée aux clayes-sous-bois 7 à
partir de 20h sur tv 78 sur la fréquence
98.4 pour radio sensations yvelines et
sachez également que vendredi soir à 20
heures vous pourrez suivre le débat avec
les candidats de la verrière un chiffre
à présent à 5 millions c'est le nombre
de maisons individuelles qui ont fait
l'objet de travaux de rénovation entre
2014 et 2016
la rénovation énergétique un secteur en
pleine croissance boostée par les aides
de l'état accordé aux ménages qui engage
ce type de travaux les entreprises
spécialisées évidemment sont en première
ligne nicolas d'andry s est rendu à
trappes
[Musique]
la rénovation énergétique permet
d'améliorer l'efficacité du logement sur
le plan thermique
ça va consister à isoler mieux les murs
renouveler l'air faire en sorte que la
maison sur la plus économe et surtout
plus confortable et ça consiste à à
venir a ajouté un isolant ou au mur
existant et ensuite venir le recouvrir
avec une protection qui va être soit un
enduit soit un bardage
ce sont des échantillons isolation par
l'extérieur
tout d'abord avec du polystyrène de la
laine de roche et de la fibre de bois on
va ensuite appliquer une couche de sous
enduit une couche de fibre de vingt deux
toiles et ensuite on va venir donc faire
le ravalement
[Musique]
et on va continuer à parler
d'environnement puisque la saison de
migration des batraciens a commencé
malheureusement chaque année certains
d'entre eux se font écraser en
traversant la route
notre journaliste marc il n 'ya piceno a
suivi nicole depuis 12 ans elle sauve
des crapauds et autres tritons le long à
des routes à gombe et son reportage en
cette saison des amours les batraciens
rejoignent leurs points de natal pour se
reproduire
seulement à gombe et l'étang de la
bruyère est séparée de la forêt par une
goutte alors depuis 12 ans nicole
s'occupe d'eux à l'aide des lycéens du
chef de tremblay sur mauldre et d'autres
bénévoles elles disposent des barrières
de 140 mètres de long financé par la
commune de gan b et le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
afin d'empêcher les batraciens de se
faire écraser les arrive effectivement
de la forêt y vont longer la bassée à un
moment ils vont tomber dans les faux et
chaque matin jusqu'au mois d'avril des
bénévoles viennent ramasser les
batraciens des sceaux pour les faire
traverser en toute sécurité
si nicole a commencé seule avec son mari
et son fils au fil des années d'autres
amoureux de la nature l'ont rejointe
comme aymeric il s'est arrêté il allait
la boulangerie rappelle et me l'a dit à
l'année prochaine vous me contacter
je viendrai vous aider
voila voila c'était contacté alors de
alors je note rahmane chaque batraciens
et répertoriés pour prouver l'efficacité
de la démarche
il y à 12 ans 500 animaux ont été sauvés
cette année les 6 ramasseurs espère
dépasser les 2500 127 crapauds mâles
dix neuf femelles et trois triton palmé
ce qui fait 149 batraciens sauvé
aujourd'hui fort de leur réussite les
bénévoles ont demandé un système plus
pérenne de bâtera co d'uc soit des
tunnels sous la route dédiée donc le pnr
tout à fait d'accord sur ça fait un an
qu'on a déposé le dossier contacté le
pnr se dit sensible à la démarche mais
le terrain est un complexe d études
hydrographique doivent être menées elles
auront lieu courant mars
[Musique]
l'actualité sportive avec notamment la
titularisation du jeune rugbyman
yvelinois fabien vite en équipe de
france u20 face au pays de galles
le match aura lieu vendredi soir dans le
cadre du troisième match du tournoi des
six nations
on rappelle que l'ancien pensionnaire du
sky rugby évolue est désormais au racing
92 et on va parler à présent d'un autre
ballon ovale celui du football américain
dominic modique aux nachi bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes joueur dans l'équipe
senior des templiers d'elancourt alors
samedi vous affrontez les docteurs
donnant c'est dans le cadre de la 4e
journée de d2 comment vous êtes préparés
pour ce match
bon on s'est préparé je pense un peu
plus mentalement parce que physiquement
on est déjà préparée
c'est ce qui nous a peiné je pense sur
le premier match de saison
parce qu'ensuite on a fait ce qu'on
appelle une remise à zéro mental et puis
j'ai tout de suite après les matchs sont
se sont déroulés beaucoup mieux que le
premier donc le physique ça va mais je
vous demande alors comment se prépare
finalement mentalement bah tout
simplement il faut arrêter de se prendre
la tête c'est ce qu'on faisait
je pense un peu trop on est on est sur
une bonne dynamique de 2 comment dire
d'action mené de bonnes choses on est
toujours sur le sur le sur comment on
appelle ça l'accompagnement jamais sur
la répression est toujours sur le ont
fait une bonne chose
on continue on fait une mauvaise chose
ben on essaye de rectifier le tir
comment ça se passe les entraînements
vous entraîner plusieurs fois dans la
semaine avant voilà pendant un match
comment ça se passe on s'entraîne deux
fois par semaine sans compter les
séances de musculation d'accord alors
votre votre adversaire donc c'est non
c'est ce que c'est une équipe que vous
connaissez
c'est une équipe que qu'on a déjà joué
il ya trois ans de mémoire
c'était lors d'un match amical donc il
n'était pas dans notre
notre division l'ac thann et sont dans
notre division donc
ça change un peu le premier à la
première rencontre on avait gagné
j'irai passer facilement on a gagné là
cette année on espère on espère pouvoir
encore décrocher la victoire
est-ce que c'est unique et dont il faut
un peu se méfier il faut se méfier
toutes les équipes parce qu'un match ne
se joue jamais avant le coup d'envoi
vous l'avez un peu évoqué tout à l'heure
justement ça fait un mois à peu près 1
que la saison a débuté
est ce qu'on peut faire un premier petit
bilan justement empressement ba
aujourd'hui on est pas mal
je voudrais je veux dire on est pas mal
sur le classement on n'est pas le
classement en fait ne montre pas
vraiment la valeur des templiers parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est troisième sur
quatre à savoir que chacun une victoire
enfin chacun une défaite pardon et des
victoires
je devrais dire que je pense qu'on est
on est on doit être premier ex-aequo
drogue d'accord donc on va dire un début
de saison plutôt positif j'ai quand même
c'est plutôt le premier match qui nous a
mis un peu
la tête sous l'eau il fuit comme là on
est sur une bonne lancée donc je pense
que la fin de saison va être un peu
mieux alors justement votre objectif
pour la fin de saison on se doute de la
réponse mais c'est quoi finalement
l'objectif c'est bah c'est toujours la
même chose d'être la meilleure équipe
est donc montée du coût en d1 et de
monter en d1
une dernière question du coup la recette
miracle là pour gagner absolument ce
match ce week-end c'est quoi pas se
prendre la tête sans courage et se
féliciter et oublier les mauvaises
choses directement cette bonne chance et
donc ce sera samedi donc à 19 heures
c'est bien ça ce soit merci dominique
modique aux nachi je rappelle que vous
êtes donc joueurs dans l'équipe des
templiers d'elancourt et donc vous
affronter ce samedi l'équipe de nantes
vous le savez les vacances touchent à
leur fin mais heureusement il reste
encore quelques jours pour profiter est
de moments en famille mélanie poké
bonsoir consorts pour votre rendez-vous
loisirs le public est attendu pour un
voyage à destination de rambouillet mais
c'est un voyage dans le temps et dans
les jouets comme à chaque de vacances
l'équipe du musée du rambo litres à vous
concocte tout plein d'animations alors
pour la première à l'accueil on va vous
remettre un livret jeu il y en a deux
sortes en fonction des âges les 3 7 ans
et les 8 12 ans à travers ce petit livre
vous revivrez l'histoire ferroviaire au
19e siècle avec un thème le temps des
machines et de jules verne
le célèbre auteur de vingt mille lieues
sous les mers et les enfants vont aussi
faire parler leur imagination
attention cette animation est proposée
sur la période que ce vendredi 21
février elle s'appelle si j'étais en
train le musée lance un défi aux
visiteurs imaginer des locomotives à
partir de trois trains qui existe déjà
mais je laisse solène la chargée
d'accueil et de médiation vous en dire
un peu plus c'est grâce au nom de ses
trains et à la description qu'on leur
donne c'est de dessiner un train pour
les plus grands d'imaginer à quoi il
pouvait ressembler et pour les plus
petits pour en coller des gommettes donc
ça c'est plutôt pour les maternelles ils
sont aidés un bien sûr c'est un moment
de partage avec les parents ou les
grandes soeurs et frères alors mélanine
question que tous les enfants se posent
et les grands enfants comme moi se pose
également
est ce qu'un petit tour de trains est
prévue et oui par contre il faut que le
temps le permettent mais solène vous
emmène en balade avec
nice est le nom de la locomotive elle
est à essence ce sont des petits tours
dans le jardin du musée pour cette
animation il faut compter 1 euro 50
en plus du droit d'entrée du musée cette
animation la a lieu le samedi 22 février
et pour ceux qui rateraient évidemment à
ces animations et bien pas d'inquiétude
les équipes ont déjà penser au prochain
rendez vous en avril et les activités
tourneront autour de l'électricité dont
les trains louer c'est bien ça mais ça
donne ça merci en tout cas on vous
retrouve bien dans quelques minutes pour
nous donner encore plus d'idées loisirs
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi et je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]